this next guest uh some might might
describe as an absolute nightmare a
dominant Force no someone that would
absolutely tear your head off and my ex
real time it
could be that and I have to say maybe
one of the better looking shirtless
human beings on the planet we see a lot
of chests I'm right here I think we got
to get it up right now for kumara
so come on
what's up brother
[Applause]
well I almost don't recognize you
without the titties out my man I didn't
even see the chest baby
it was a joke come on I'm sorry
three times absolutely terrifying how
are you brother I'm good man hold on
what's going on over here what happened
over here oh just a little you know
because I'm one of those Full Throttle
type of guys yeah anything is kind of if
anything is uh someone's messed up or
impaired I don't care I just want to
just
get right back into the [ __ ] now this is
this this is to protect yeah a little
something needs to protect me from going
too quick and then hurting myself and
then having to setbacks yeah you know
this is for a little government other
people's yeah because that is yeah that
is the jab well you can see it's
removable
so if we needed to get into this [ __ ]
right now another confetti popper it
might come up let's go UFC is paying
well bro
we got the Rollies
[Applause]
are you doing some movies
I know I know
he's right here these are nice bro is it
okay if he sees it yeah
yesterday you did your thing brother
thank you thank you oh I thought amazing
really amazing bro how do you feel good
you saw it it was weird talk to me it
was weird I mean it's um you know what
look at you you can't now you can't not
lose you son you look good you look good
the weight in taking these up like how
serious does that fit look at this hold
up hold on I'm sorry
my heart almost kind of right I'm sorry
like some guys looks at your girl like
yo what were you looking at don't do
that
was [ __ ] up dude I just want to see if
you can block it bro do you take these
off dude you can't put them back you
gotta fight
you take these off
okay the sun gets nervous bro that's
crazy
you're in absolute huge Blockbuster
going to be probably one of the biggest
movies ever but also one of the biggest
movies this year
um
do you ever think as a kid that you're
going to end up in a [ __ ] Marvel
franchise no not not Marvel I I uh you
know as a kid you always think oh man
like that's cool that's so cool
most like just like my whole journey
right now you know in life even getting
to where I am and my uh my professional
fighting career it's uh I never dreamed
that I would be here you know I was like
I started wrestling in high school and
I'm just like oh man I just want to
maybe make it to State and I got to the
point where it's like I'm on Wednesday
then you get to where it's like I want
to go to college and it's like I'm a win
Nationals then you get to the point
where it's like
I'm gonna go win the Olympics yeah then
pivot to where it's like you know what
let me go make a lot of money
and now it's the point where you know
you you were championed defended
multiple times and it's like uh after I
saw the first one I'm like
it makes sense
you know African you know this movie is
based on African superhero yeah
I feel like I'm about to fight so why
not I should definitely be in this movie
yeah so I kept just kind of speaking
about it speaking about it and I talked
to my manager about it oh you know
when I first you know said it but that
was the first one came out what like 20
2016 was it 2016 four years oh no longer
than that 2016 I think yeah and so you
know in between that I was you know I'm
like yeah I would love to be in it and
then Chad passed away so yeah I had no
idea they were gonna do another one yeah
and then you know all of a sudden I get
a call like hey
okay okay is there a different energy
when you're doing fight scenes and like
there are people who are there to teach
you how to fight and you're like but
that was that was the crazy thing is I
don't really fight yeah I wish you in
this yeah I haven't seen it yet but it's
been utilizing right yeah but at least
they didn't kill me off so I could
always come back okay okay and so I
think later on they're gonna you know
this I can get into the [ __ ] like okay
but okay it was like being there they
just had so much it was so much star
power yeah and it was just like um just
to be there and actually see these
professionals how they do this I was I
remember it was the second day on set we
were there for 15 hours I wasn't talking
I was just in the background of the
scene and I stood for 15 hours wow I
left that day saying never again I don't
know
[Laughter]
it's the most boring [ __ ] Bro making
movies boring [ __ ] dude really hurry up
and wait yeah that's it see there at
seven in the morning they pick over six
and you just stand around 5 45 they
picked us up yeah were you nervous at
all like getting on cam like yo the
first my first day
first scene that I was in I'm actually
innocence my talking scene I'm talking
yeah and I'm in front of Angela Bassett
and you know just everyone all the big
actors in that room in the war room and
I'm uh I'd have to explain to her what
just happened
and and I remember I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah that's Stella
are you married no no I'm not married
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah it was it was crazy getting to be
on set with just that much
that many professionals
oh God
no but it's respectfully it was
respectfulness yeah it's just no we we
we're doing the movie yeah and I'm going
through the scene and I'm just like oh
that's Stella yeah I remember watching
her in Hostel I got a Groove man and I
was wishing I was Tay Diggs and I was
like I was like he looked like me I
could I could you know
and now we we do the movie and I'm
they're doing the scenes over and over
and over and over and I'm just like
[ __ ] they one day we did a scene Maybe
40 times you know it was just the same
thing over and over because then they
got to change cameras yeah they got to
change angles they got to do this to do
that they do the scene and
Angela and uh deny or and some they they
do the scene and it was they shot it
with the same intensity every time yeah
yeah all day we were there
I was gonna get an award really yeah bro
I was literally like moving [ __ ] yeah we
was we were the whole cat we was
clapping everything really every take
we'd clap all right cut change angles
boom now it's another 45 minutes come
back do this thing again everyone's
clapping yeah come back do this thing
everyone's almost crying I'm like really
goosebumps every time they did this
thing I'm nervous that you would mess up
your lines were you nervous to like and
did you at all at one line
one line I was scared I was gonna [ __ ]
up or something a lot what's the line
what's the line I can't tell you that I
mean it's out the movies out okay
okay I can't do that bro but uh oh got
you oh you deliver some news but I did I
did I actually talked yeah so you know
so but it was like one line yourself in
the like no that's what I'm saying it's
weird you know how you hear your voice
yeah you're like damn I sound like that
it's like I understand why people try to
fight me
I was watch it's different watching now
film knowing behind the scenes like I
watched the first one and it was the
coolest thing I've ever seen I was like
oh my god oh look at the spaceship yeah
oh look at this you know yeah and then
not being a part of it I was like oh
that was the spaceship yeah all the
green screen you know I was like oh
that's where they were at yeah you know
but it was it was incredible just seeing
them put it all together I mean the the
director Ryan was the amine right it's
brilliant guy huh really it was the
funniest thing is when I first got on
set and met him and you know it Compton
was a person that's Ryan that's Ryan
he's real yes
he sounds just like he front Compton
yeah yeah you know it sounds just like
that yeah you know he walked just like
that he got the bot you know that comes
to bot when he walks and he's the
coolest nicest he makes sure everybody's
good on set you good everything good
with you yeah like and I was just like
wow yeah but think about think about how
important that is like
you're going to that situation this is a
massive moment you see all these famous
people and I I felt it even doing acting
stuff where like around these people who
have like admired and looked up to for
years and now you're getting a scene
with them and you're like you don't want
to let them down you don't want like
you've got so much nerves so he got to
fill you up with some confidence and
letting you know yeah that's the thing
he does very well too is his direction
is is spot on like he's he's really good
his vision is really really good so
doing it and
um and I'm that day we're on set we're
doing the lines boom this person goes
this person goes this person goes and
I'm just so in awe of everyone going I'm
just like yeah yeah and then there's a
pause Whose Line is it yeah
I thought Drew Carey was there
it's like who's lied I'm like I have one
line
do you have more respect for actors now
absolutely really yeah absolutely but
that day I stood for 15 hours yeah
that's a lot my back was destroyed yeah
and I you know I destroyed yeah I went
back saying I needed a massage and I
hadn't done anything that day except
Stan yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] now
would you would you you think acting is
a little bit more uh in play in the
future absolutely how many more years of
fighting you think me yeah ah I can't
really put a
before I used to like you know put a you
know
put a number on it like you know because
you know when you Champion you just
beating everybody beating them and
beating them and beating them it's like
after a while yeah you gotta after a
while you gotta find something to
motivate yourself to go well now you
have motivation so now now it's like oh
hell no we're gonna go back yeah we'll
go over there we're gonna you know spin
the block on this dude real quick yeah
after we get that you know and then
we'll see how how much thrill there is
again but it's you know I'm almost
thankful that it's a it's a new thrill
yeah I'm one of those kind of guys who I
like okay do you have like when you look
at people I think that was one of the
things about about Jordan that was so
impressive is that even for the littlest
game he could like trick himself
absolutely psychologically yeah do the
same thing okay so it's like you know
you're not as excited to fight this guy
that you can beat but you have to hit a
gear yeah to motivate yourself in
training yeah and what is that now you
have the real one different different
things is for different people you know
I I per se I don't spend a lot of time
on social media anymore yeah yeah but
something you know it'd be the one day
that I'm like oh you know what let me
let me scroll up one or two and I hear
something I'll see something it's like
oh and that's the fire that's how you
feel
okay and dude has already said a couple
things and and that's already it's
filled the cup yeah what does he do it's
a nothing yeah it's been enough was
there was there a moment
was there a moment afterwards like I'm
sure you watched it and you reflected it
where you were like did you make a
mistake that you don't usually make or
was there like oh [ __ ] I need to fix
that part no it was I needed to fix
something because I like no one comes
into a fight 100 but I was dealing with
some things that didn't allow me to do
what I wanted to do oh and so I I I
remember what I was setting up to do
because at that moment when it happened
I was plotting something and I remember
what I was playing like when I fought
most of the second time I was plotting
you were setting that up the whole time
and I'm moving like if everybody goes
back and watches the fight you know I
did almost the same thing in in that
finishing sequence as I did in the
beginning of the fight and but I was
this time I was plotting I'm plotting
I'm reading I'm Computing what he's
doing and I'm like oh this you don't
really think it's coming and then it'll
happen and then the same thing with this
I'm kind of trying to plot and but I
certain things for my body wasn't moving
the way that I wanted it to yeah and um
and I just didn't I thought I was ready
to do what I wanted to do but I wasn't
ready because I didn't put them in the
position to do it and so what happened
and next thing I remember I remember
thinking all that
I remember sitting in the ambulance like
God damn it no
no yeah
it's it's different I mean it's it's I
guess it's what makes this sport so
loving and so amazing because it's like
you know I've never been in that
situation yeah you know I've put a lot
of people in that situation but I've
never been in that situation to where
and then you it's like all of a sudden
for me it was like someone turned the
lights off on turn it back on Wow and it
was just like I'm fine nothing happened
yeah I don't I'm just like I'm good yeah
and I'm sitting there like damn it yeah
yeah you got me didn't he
it's wild it was yeah it was yeah it was
um
it's it's humbling and it's for me it
wasn't like that's the thing is I feel
like the world was more upset about it
than I was well and then yeah why do you
think that was
um I think your dominance may be in the
yeah yeah I mean it's I mean because I
feel like people have been accustomed to
knowing that when I step out there what
I've put in and the body of work that
they're gonna get it's weird the
expectation of dominance it's like yeah
yeah it's a it's and I think Izzy goes
through this as well sometimes too it's
like it's like oh if he doesn't go out
there put himself in complete [ __ ]
danger knock somebody out in the first
30 seconds it's like oh what's going on
here two people have to engage
and it's like we were so used to
dominance from you and then we were
getting it that's the thing the first
round it was really interesting was like
oh [ __ ] whatever and then I felt like
you saw something you start to put on
sauce yeah it's you know I'm I'm a
respectful guy yeah you know and then in
the first round it was like I'm
respectful to a certain level don't step
Don't don't be a habitual lion stepper
don't don't don't step he stepped over
the line and thought this was always
sweet like I was like I'm like oh what
was the moment where you felt that when
I got up
because he he he had he he tripped
tripped my leg he hooked it and my I
wanted to throw him over but my knee
kind of got caught and I fell on my back
I was worried me then I know so I just I
just stayed down I was like you know
what you know it's like one of those
like you know Big Brother little brother
I'm like if I get up you win some [ __ ]
and if you go back and watch that the
end of that first run I got up I was
like it's on
I jog back I laughed back in my corn I
was I was I was laughing on the inside
like oh it's about to go so so you feel
extremely confident going into yeah
always because the thing is no every
fight every I have to feel that way
because of the work that I put in I
break my body over and over and over
just to prepare for that fight
like it's the fight is just a bonus just
to make it to the fight that's the bonus
people get to see just the fun part
that's just fun you know it's training
to get there yeah that's it that's the
hard part that's these dudes being you
different dudes beating you up every day
you know and that's the hard part being
able to get through that and do the
weight cut and make the way get into
that then you're like oh now I get to
have fun tomorrow so Camp is really
[ __ ] tough it's tough for me yes
definitely with the fire that I put
myself through each and every time and
when I get through that and go into a
fight I'm like nothing's worse than this
okay okay so then here's my question you
have
a beautiful daughter yes you have money
you have success you have Fame how much
harder is it to motivate you
yourself into putting you into the most
dangerous situation that's legal like
it's oh I mean life is still life is
great yeah but it's mine but it's it's
my day it's my job it's what I do and
that's the thing is when I got into it I
wasn't like oh um you know I have to
make this has to happen this has to work
you won't no I chose it yeah you know I
went to school yeah yeah
I used it in the office and you know get
my type on yeah but there are people who
don't have an option this was your
choice this was my choice and so with
that choice I'm every day I choose to
get up I choose to work I chose to work
as hard as I did to get to the you know
the level that I did but isn't it harder
like I don't know
I'm gonna I'm gonna say it was it was
like the famous it was Marvin Hagler
that said that it's you know it's a lot
tougher to get motivated to get up when
you're sleeping on so she's like yeah
yeah you know and I I got some skills
bro
so I have I understand that me what that
means yeah you know there there are some
times like now you know there's some
it's so easy to just be like
you know what I don't have anything to
like let's say the doctor's like oh you
hurt your hand take a month off
you could just go I'm usually like okay
I'm two days off I'm like all right
let's let me just go bike or let me just
shadow box let me do something you know
I'm always like that yeah but now you
know it's so much easier to be like
relax the doctor
I'm cool
you know I I kind of see that and I
caught myself in them that's good but it
is hard and I I can't do it you know
what just for even thinking that running
extra mile yeah but isn't that crazy
like that's a motivation that a lot of
people don't know like people who want
to come up and haven't made some money
and had some success and also have
family like it's one thing if you have
if you don't have family right because
yeah your whole life and identity can
revolve around this thing but it from
what I see on Instagram I don't [ __ ]
know it seems like you're very active in
your daughter's life oh yeah so so it's
like that I imagine is the most
important thing to you yeah big time so
there are people who don't have kids
so they don't realize
MMA is your hobby yeah your job you know
what I'm saying like your identity is
now you've got to go make that money so
that she can eat and she can have good
life but once you make the money and you
have it now you've got to find another
[ __ ] gear to go to oh yeah and that's
what that's what makes the greats it's
it's
I understand what they mean when it's
tougher to stay there you know for me
not even now I tell some of the younger
guys that you know they look at you and
they're like oh man I want to drive that
I'm you I see what you're driving I want
to drive that you know and I'm just like
man I don't understand that's y'all
living the best times right now and the
best times is like when I all I had to
do was just train yeah go back home
hungry yeah you know be excited to go
back to the gym and train again that
night that that was the best times yeah
no one was asking anything of you
everything was nodded any you was not a
walking lick for anybody you know like
that was the best times yeah right when
you Champion it's like oh you gotta go
do the shoot here yeah you got to go fly
here and do that yep oh you gotta do
that interview you gotta do this do that
with all this time that you're spending
doing all that that's time you're not
training you represent the organization
bro yeah and and so your your your
Ascension is not as you know rapid as it
is you know when you got all these
different things pulling you this way
this way this one this way yeah and you
got you know a daughter that you gotta
feed or a family that you want to retire
your mom and dad you want to do all
these things you know all of that play
into account which is staying a champion
and the Champions that are able to
defend it's it's impressive I mean to
defend and then do it again it's crazy
mind-blowing and then I understood that
the more and more because that is more
and more weight each and every time yeah
all right guys we gotta take a break for
a second because it's time to get
healthy okay we're gonna get healthy the
quick and easy way with one delicious
scoop of athletic greens one ag1 right
here you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help start your day right okay this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
and aging all the things literally okay
ag1 is a small micro habit with massive
benefits you're going to be sleeping
better the quality is going to be so
improved of your recovery specifically
the mental Clarity and alertness you're
gonna get and it costs you less than
three dollars a day you're investing in
your health and it's cheaper than your
cold brew habit think about that right
now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements look out for your health to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com flagrant again that
is athleticgreens.com flagrant to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
now let's get back to the show look I
know like every day of training is
different but can you take us through
like your routine like when you're
training hardcore oh when I mean when
I'm in cam yeah when I'm in Camp it's
it's that's the thing it's a full-time
game it's not you know you wake up
usually I get it time to I like to train
early okay so
you know the first Camp I did with
Trevor I think we were going to 8 A.M
but um I think the last one we're doing
nine nine a.m but I'm up maybe let's say
if I'm training at 8am I'm up maybe six
so you get up you know take a little bit
I'm getting a little older now so I'll
take a little bit
a little bit warm up then you got to go
down and get the breakfast in you know
get your supplements in and then drive
to the gym be there you know maybe 30
minutes early try to warm up
and then start training at nine he takes
you through that training session
whatever he has dialed up for that day
go through it maybe an hour and a half
and then usually I want to do something
else after quickly get something in a
couple minutes then shower go home
physical therapist is there working on
you then you eat and then after you're
done eating you might have something to
do that day maybe an interview or
something real quick try to get that in
then you might have like an hour in
between and maybe take a nap I'm not a
napper so I'm just sitting there maybe I
want to watch a you know special you
know the new engine show special event
I actually did watch that dude I mean
yeah actually I'm really glad I watched
that during my last Camp so thank you
man get that in real quick then it's
like look at the clock It's Five O'Clock
[ __ ] it's time to get ready for
practicing another one yeah you grab
your bags gotta you know pack everything
gotta drive maybe 30 minutes of practice
go to practice get another hour happen
then it's you want to get some
stretching in after you know got to go
somewhere get some stretching in and
then maybe get in the hot tub come back
eat dinner it's already nine whole day
go to sleep eight week Camp do it all
over again I I'm I'm almost like in Camp
constantly constantly it's just like the
intensity is not right here yeah yeah
when it's like you sign the dotted line
you have an opponent that's when it's
like okay yeah I'm gonna kick this guy's
ass that's I'm focused on this guy so
yeah the intensity dials up for that
have you ever fought someone who you
kind of liked
yeah and is that harder
a little bit yeah it's harder a guy who
thought was like hey he's kind of a good
guy I don't think he who I kind of like
I mean I like Gilbert until we had to
throw down yeah he wanted to fight me so
um I liked RDA interesting yeah and
liked RDA and training for him was like
you know yeah no I I like this guy but
then I was watching
his interviews and he was starting to
talk and he said something that's it he
was like oh
you gonna do that yeah yeah you love it
when they say something because now you
got your motivation now you got it on
fire and I said it before you know I I'm
I'm out from Texas I'm the judge
so I'm listening and and now to the
point where my my parents are like the
biggest I don't even watch anything like
my parents are the biggest fans they had
me on Google Google Alerts yeah anything
comes up on Instagram anything comes up
on YouTube they they calling me like you
heard what this month
my mom's like did you hear what this boy
said
I'm like what do you say Mom what do you
saying yeah but he thinks he's just
going to he's walking on me
wow is your mom at a lot of your fights
yeah since uh the first fight she well
she came to the ultimate fighter yeah
when I won that yeah and then didn't
come to another fight until I fought for
the title and what's she at the title
fight
yes she was at the title fight when I
got the title and then she's been in
every fight ever since wow when I fought
Covington yeah first time yeah you can
hear my mom
TV like it's funny but you can hear her
that's funny if I watch the fight right
now yeah you hear her the whole fight
yeah she's just screaming Kamara come on
come the whole fight I'm like are you
serious
can you hear her when you're in there
like no not when I'm fighting because
you're just right that fight I couldn't
even I didn't even hear my coaches oh
wow that fight I was
nothing was going like it's almost
giving me the Vibes that I'm feeling for
this with this one so it's coming it's
almost like nothing's gonna
like DMX or whoever uh Jetty cassette
now this is gonna uh Nothing's Gonna
Make Me Feel Better except for blood
like I was I came to that fight like
yeah we gotta get like the world was not
gonna be satisfied like I could have
been like when I fought him a second
time I could have been talked to use
tactics and and moved around and played
with it you wanted this I won the fight
no I was all about the smoke the first
one can I ask you a question
so you when you come with like a
wrestling background is it and I've seen
certain guys is it easy to get and then
you find out that you're a good Striker
as a lot of wrestling guys are and I
wonder if there's like hip motion that
makes uh wrestling guys be uh translate
to striking better than like Jiu Jitsu
guys but but my question for you is this
is it easy to get seduced by the hands
once you know you have them
I mean of course
and is that too if I could hit you with
one shot and you fall over and I go home
I ain't gotta do you get a new account
that sounds pretty good yeah yeah yeah
yeah I like that might as well come in
you know 10 seconds my mom you know go
home get that check yeah yeah I'm good
with that I'm good with that at what
point do you think I'm not career in a
minute exactly that's the best way to
fight is to just pull guard as soon as
the fight yeah yeah then it's like oh
you know well yeah that's why I have sex
all right babe let's go let's get you
backstage and use say some you you
finger your balls
bro yeah I don't know what happened back
there like I don't know I was saying
something and he and it made me think
sometimes
oh you do it now yeah yeah I thought you
meant your private life
[ __ ] I adjusted my [ __ ] but I did it
with one finger for some reason it
looked Wild know why I did that
sometimes you got hit with the Raptor
you know what I mean like
you gotta take it back to Jurassic Park
so yeah I did that but you notice it
which is weird because you've never
looked at my balls this whole interview
but he was looking so by the end of this
episode he's going to figure his balls
watch yeah
take off the braids yeah
what's up with the love life man that's
what I need to know what's up with the
lovely life the love life yeah is it
crazy or what now that you're a
Hollywood Superstar uh I mean no I was
uh I was in a relationship for all of
last year so all through the the Gilbert
the master doll and Kobe all of 21 I was
in the relationship you know and so and
you know all that time wasted all that
good time
[Laughter]
and that was hand smoke
he needs a little bit of help
no but uh yeah I was in a relationship
until earlier this this year Okay so
yeah I'm single but I'm not really like
like don't get it wrong we all like girl
but but I'm I'm like a I like love I
know you know I'm talking about I like
love oh you know what you're doing feel
me I like you know what you're doing
right now no I'm just you know what
you're doing right now I like love
I like that he's a great father
's like wow
I like a hot girl but I like her
personality
[Laughter]
you get to a certain point where you
realize that you know after you get that
post-nut Clarity yeah
it's it's like
so what you about to do yeah
you know and if it if it's someone just
that's cool yeah you don't have to ask
that you're just like
you wanna get something to eat you know
you wanna you wanna go down to this
arcade you want to go do something yeah
yeah you know that that right now is
just a little bit more important to me
yeah you know but of course they got you
know that looks brings you to the table
like they bring you to the table it
brings you to the table Yeah you got a
crush you got a little celebrity crush
celebrity crush I had a few I got a few
yeah who you plotting on bro so no but I
was uh I was just at the uh blue pizza
or what
the Kayla look at Kohl's here oh yeah
that's my dog
you guys know you know that's the homies
you guys know you guys know mechanical
yeah
[Music]
hold me chilling with the boys
[Music]
I mean uh incredible beautiful smart
like like the thing with her is uh we
were both in a movie together oh and and
we would like all clicked me her and
Winston who's umbaku in the movie yeah
we like that was like my crew yeah and
uh the thing with her was just like
I never been around because I didn't
know who she was until and I started I
got their names and I started
researching I was like oh yeah a big
deal yeah yeah you know and then um
I couldn't believe how cool they were
yeah you know because
they're Hollywood people were Hollywood
oh I know that absolutely
yeah Hollywood yeah you know you'll be
texting with somebody you know like but
backstage y'all talking cool yeah then
y'all go out in front and be like hey
what's up yep don't even know you yeah
wow I'm like oh not little pizza though
not that's Pizza yes I mean Pizza though
I mean she could be but the thing is I I
could she looks the other way like you
get better yeah
yeah no yeah no no come on
we didn't know how talented
it's not even my drink I'm a respectful
man no but it's not all the time it goes
90 degrees
90 degrees
I went to the premiere
in L.A yeah and it was I mean I know
talking about celebrities it was crazy
it was ridiculous you've never seen
someone I mean Jay-Z Beyonce ASAP
Toby was that yeah they were every and
I'm looking around I'm seeing all these
actors and actresses everywhere and I
see um what's there's this girl I just I
just seen her name
something about Tiana
she would have she would have been there
but
um
I remember her from this uh it was a
show that you should watch on HBO called
How to Make It in America how to make it
America yeah yeah it was the the the
white chick from there
it's like a different it's a different
vibe it's not you know she's a different
vibe but it was like yeah yeah
yeah
and then Tessa Tessa Thompson
like you know yeah take that but you
know I've seen him at the the premiere
but I didn't want to smash up on them
because you don't want to creep them out
because they doing a Hollywood dude you
know so you don't want to just pull up
yo what's up yeah how you doing yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I do have some Hollywood crush it but
who's the who's the the number one
Hollywood crush with all due respects
not even sexually just a crush yeah it's
just a little something I mean
definitely sexually but I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm an old head at heart yeah yeah
me too like the Julia Roberts still oh
Julius Julius the wrong one bro
it really is
they're still at the at the top
remixed that
it's nice I think Julie is absolutely
gorgeous Julia can't do nothing wrong
Ocean's 11. I don't think she's
beautiful the ocean's 12. I think she's
she's cool she's great but throw out a
feeling it's awesome
new ones
I know you're not saying Julia Roberts
is your dream girl
[Music]
Lupita of course you know Michaela
Cole's beautiful Michaela
say hi and uh she's out there she's out
there so he has to go no
um okay they're telling us there's a few
there's a few but it's like I I'm I'm
drawing a blank right now because it's
just so many yeah you won't be shooting
blanks media this is what we've done
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's practice some lines
I wish I had a study buddy
buddy
but it's dating in South Florida is not
the greatest why what is it South
Florida Floridians bro oh yeah what do
you mean what's wrong with Floridians
I'm from Florida those are my people
from Florida yeah yeah life Central my
wife's from Central Florida Central
Florida
Orlando Disney World that's not South
Florida yeah
it's crazy South Florida different
country only fans
oh yeah that's that's that's different
yeah they're they're but it's just it's
just it's just a um
the caliber of what's what's important
what's important after that like after
the post-nut clarity
what's left what's left and it's not
there you know and then it's just like a
lot of people are opposing you know the
men females deposing to be something
that they're not necessarily so you want
a connection absolutely
absolutely but with some other things
yeah what
I mean I mean you know but if you found
your person yeah and y'all want to get
into the [ __ ] yeah that's between y'all
y'all that's between y'all yeah like you
and usually if you you might one day you
might run into this yeah Tiana you'd be
like yeah I gotta have Tiana babies make
that happen for me
you know
that's between y'all I'm just a fan of
her work yeah yeah
can I respect the art I'm disrespecting
the art you know what I mean you know
what I just watched this this show on
Hulu I thought you were talking about I
just watched this Porn Bro
I just watched this show on on Hulu
called uh God God uh
or is it God God forbid okay it's like
this uh documentary on um something the
guy that was the head of Liberty
University and his wife like that they
were like yeah they're like King makers
but then they had this little pool boy
in Miami that they would get down yes
bro this story is crazy yeah yeah true
story and uh just watch that but in the
whole time yeah they're saying all these
things and everything's going down but
I'm thinking I'm like what a guy
you know
I love your wife that much yeah you're
like baby you want the pool boy you
could have me yeah I just want to sit
over here and watch
[Laughter]
I'm like I don't get it either but I'm
like think how much love you gotta have
for me
you want but you want her to be happy
that so badly yeah to where you were
like ah go ahead do your thing yo but do
you think I'm just gonna jerk in the
corner can I ask y'all a serious
question do you think he still cleans
the pool though oh the dude like yeah
like the pool's way Messier now
like he got a little bread from them
like you gotta you guys gotta watch this
but he kept being the pool cleaner but
he's now this was fascinating no they
had put him on he got some businesses
okay he was checking the pH though yeah
yeah for sure for sure yeah
okay they're telling us that you got to
go yeah I gotta go listen brother thank
you so much man yeah go go handle
business I'm so excited bro we're coming
out there yeah this is dope man yeah
we'll see you at the fight yeah
congratulations
on the table in the shades
I'm gonna have a gift basket for you
guys also oh that's what I like next
time I come back next time
thank you milis appreciate you damn wow
that was one of the best things you ever
did right now yeah I'm surprised you
didn't just bring over a trash bag of
water I thought that's what you're gonna
do I thought he was gonna put in his
hand just bro how Charming is Camaro yo
come on remarkable I hope we ain't get
up in trouble though
dude that was funny dude that was funny
oh Charming yeah for real yeah for real
I think you could ask man oh yeah I
gotta do you really like the movie yeah
it was it was really good phenomenal so
that's the thing directors bro like yeah
he he's up there now like he was already
up there but to be able to top something
that was so good I wouldn't say it's
better but it's as good
and the first one was really good
usually when the first movie is like
like Matrix to one like
two is not as good but this [ __ ] is fire
really they didn't ask you to be in
Black Panther they did oh they did yeah
that's great and did you did it or no
I'm in it it's just one white guy in it
oh and they call him a colonizer the
whole time I love it yeah
well is he is he though I mean that's
what they referred to in that role no
he's like FBI but they just referred to
him as the cops come on bro it's a
little crazy give us a shot there's
gotta be one good white guy you know
what I mean yeah also you got all that
technology stop the colonization like
what the [ __ ] what's going on here like
you got all the technology yeah Tech is
to keep these [ __ ] out we just
have that little place yes
the little land right here we good [ __ ]
all y'all but then the water the the
water Mexicans came for y'all
Mexican stay for y'all bro that is great
Mexican he's Mexican the guy who plays
oh Mexican yeah yeah but the water
Mexican